you to want ce paysage ambiant se trouve
sur hit other alors nous une sorte de
deux drops de barques de rocker qui
quittent qui dansent sur les tables et
qui équivaut à sa tête baissée voilà bon
c'est qu'on est pas celle où est ce
qu'on peut espérer que ça d'accord on
peut boire de manière totalement normal
est gratuite faut qu'on trouve des clés
ghislaine plé hockey et bla pain est
boxeur professionnel centre latapie
temps du père pendant dix ans il y en a
qu'on espèce de pochettes rahal et lyon
or on a vu un accouplement au direct
salut je t'aime à moi ok bonne journée à
mon avis à des vigiles et on s'en bat
les 180 latine voilà qu'est ce qui a
obligé casillas
j'avais oublié de vider la carte mémoire
de la caméra donc je suis mort messieurs
céder son big whiskey c'est vraiment des
êtres humains l'huile un truc à la main
ok ok on est dans la merde et je ne vous
permet pas de me toucher
laissez moi alors qu'est ce tu sais qui
c'est on sait que sa voix la ouate même
les vigiles sont bien au sénat fait ce
soir
ouais l'objet excuse moi est ce que tu
fais des crises d'épilepsie debout route
urdens vraiment a tendance à arette
alors ascquois watts
oh mon dieu on peut carrément regarder
ce soir on pratique un côté spécial avec
un canard
allez on peut donner son vote les steaks
où il voit un mec normal cela des
quelqu'un bord je te jure agence dessus
watts c a tué et pourquoi tu cours tu
m'attaques tout le temps peut-être parce
que je l'étape mais c'est pas y discute
et on en a une
ouais ah c'est pas un coup de merde que
je me suis pris en mai qu'il a fait ça
allez hop tu t'envoles là-bas temps des
essais trop galère là vient la russe
c'est bon il a tapé voilages et la
deuxième et la troisième est celle où on
a les trois clés assez bon on peut s'en
aller assez c'est juste ça le jeu merde
ok la deuxième la deuxième kate serait
d'avoir tous les disques j'aime pas rock
watts sans cheat planus hongren ok très
bien mais je sais que les mecs je vais
même j'ai fait ce que je suis je sais
jouer de la flûte du banjo je veux plein
de trucs les gens je sais jouer peloton
il suffit juste de demander
on aurait dit un [ __ ] de poule est
poursuivi par un mec qui a pas mangé
depuis dix ans quand on est au bon bah
on va voir un prétexte et voilà comme ça
puis la platine à y manquer ok manque de
truc moi je suis vigilant le vigile de
la montée à tous ceux qui mentent mal à
thé mal monté faire d'ailleurs voilà
pardon plutôt des colis c'est pas des
trucs watts
ok très bien voilà qu'est ce qu'il ya
moi je te tue avec la cuvette de
toilette monga ok pas le malin et hop
oh merde oh la la patine qui puisent aux
platines photo scheer vous inquiétez pas
je met de la musique ne me tuez pas
messieurs dames tel manque un truc c'est
l'atelier cassage donné ici présents
dans ce bar actuellement c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe ici à mr
deuil sont trop puissants mois du
tournoi à sa première je suis bloqué
excusez moi quelqu'un pour javier mas
des à tout le monde s'emballe et steq
d'accord avec avec sa tablette juste à
temps des fléaux et ceci était une
embuscade dans ses bons à la platine à
l'entretien 10 excuse moi ou vous êtes
trop chine
moi je danse avec mes toilettes est ce
qu'on s'amuse les gens il est là elle
est là non non mais c'est moi laissez
moi c'est moi non non elle était là elle
était là les la mecque
il est là il est là je ne peux pas je
refuse ce mec qui a le record du monde
débats les plus longs quoi le breil fond
il faut mais ta gueule on a la mine
c'est tout pas on à la mixette honda 17e
d'accord luxe bad trip c'est pas grave
on va pouvoir se faire c'est le trou du
cul à terme jouer à un maintien en super
8 6 5 4 3 2 pour que je me fixe ou fait
du bruit au rouge génocide à la canette
jean pierre tu veux de cannes est du
genre et 4 mais [ __ ] mais c'est vrai
je n'arrive pas à me faire quoi tu
pourrais passer le balai avec son bras
tu pourrais te servir de son code barre
de traction et une immense son bras
c'est n'importe quoi
ouah il s'est passé un truc bizarre avec
70 voix là ça va pas du tout une sorte
de deux bouts de bois dans la colonne
donc c'est comme ça que tu fais de la
batterie un fait du bruit pour moi même
si les 9/10 d'entre vous sont morts par
mes points et les bras de khat est il un
problème tout petit vous
et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo sur in other j'espère que ça
vous aura plu en tout cas c'était
sacrément what the fuck aujourd'hui en
tout cas merci à toi d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo c'est super cool et on se
retrouve déjà vendredi à 17h30 pour une
nouvelle vidéo sur ma chaîne restez
comme vous êtes vous êtes top
et puis à vendredi tu as tout le monde s
high five ouais ça peut chez vous de
faire ça tout seul devant son cadavre
mais bon c'est pas grave bien marrante
instruct fatah soit qu'ils aient la
regarder ajoute en premier aux pédales a
vaincu la crau